[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 en el año 2020 la
revista feminista latinoamericana
volcánicas publicó 8 denuncias de acoso
y abuso sexual contra Ciro guerra un
artículo en el que relató detalladamente
las historias de mujeres víctimas en el
director colombiano de cine famoso
además por producciones como el abrazo
de la serpiente que en su día fue
nominada al Oscar guerra respondió con
una demanda y pidiendo un millón de
dólares en compensación el caso acaba de
resolverse y protegió al periodismo
feminista Pues bien la corte de Suprema
de Justicia de Colombia acaba de fallar
en favor de las periodistas autoras de
Catalina Ruiz Navarro y Matilde de los
milagros londoño y además el artículo no
va a ser retirado guerra perdió la
batalla que inició argumentando una
defensa de su buen nombre y una supuesta
falta de rigurosidad en el reportaje que
lo expuso como un violento con las
mujeres
Aquí vamos a reflexionar sobre el
desenlace de este caso y para ello
invitamos a una de las autoras del
artículo de volcánicas Matilde de los
milagros londoño Matilde felicitaciones
por su Victoria judicial y bienvenida a
ella soy
Hola Ángela Cómo estás Mil gracias por
esta invitación Estoy muy feliz de
recibirla sobre todo dadas las
circunstancias y dado este fallo de la
corte constitucional no era para menos
el artículo que publicó volcánicas en
2020 usted diría Matilde que también fue
un escrache porque este método es para
ustedes una herramienta válida no
solamente de denuncias sino
eventualmente de reparación y también de
no repetición
Pues bueno Yo te diría que este
reportaje periodístico fue un paso Más
allá del escrache el escrache No
necesariamente cuenta con una
corroboración periodística Y en este
reportaje nosotros seguimos todos los
parámetros
nacionales e internacionales
periodísticos para hacer una
contrastación de fuentes para hacer
comprobación de modo tiempo y lugar
entonces yo creo que el periodismo
feminista como medio de denuncia de
violencia sexual va un paso más allá que
les del escrache y coincide con el
escrache gracias a este fallo de la
corte en que en que está protegido
constitucionalmente y está una de las
cosas históricas que dice este fallo de
la corte es que el periodismo feminista
es fundamental para la construcción de
una democracia en donde no haya
violencia y en donde haya igualdad
entonces Y dice además algo que es
demasiado importante y es que los
testimonios de las víctimas de violencia
sexual por ser provenientes de una
población históricamente discriminada
tienen una protección especial
constitucional entonces pues es un
respaldo muy grande al periodismo
feminista como género periodístico y
también en la corte se menciona mucho el
escrache porque por supuesto Pues
digamos que tienen cosas tienen cosas en
común es una forma de denuncia no no
penal
no judicial en donde se narran historias
de víctimas Entonces
entonces si el periodismo feminista
digamos que va un pasito más adelante
del escrache pero ambas cosas están
protegidas por la corte y cumple además
la función de proteger pero también de
denunciar para que en el futuro pues
otras mujeres puedan estar protegidas
frente a hombres que pueden ser
presuntos al menos acosadores y
abusadores ahora usted Matilde que las
denuncias de guerra constituyeron en
efecto un caso además de acoso
judiciales sin proponérselo guerra tuvo
acceso a la justicia y una situación de
poder que no reflejaba igualdad en el
caso Además él les pedía un millón de
dólares a qué horas uno va a pagar un
millón de dólares con un trabajo de
periodista
pues Ángela de hecho nos pedía un millón
y medio de dólares y yo no creo que él
haya sido una persona que
inadvertidamente nos causó un acoso
judicial yo creo que eso fue una
estrategia absolutamente deliberada y no
solamente lo creo yo sino que lo cree la
corte constitucional una de las cosas
que dice el fallo es que Ciro guerra
tuvo un uso desproporcionado de los
medios jurídicos un uso en donde hay una
evidente desbalance de poder Entre él
como una persona con medio suficientes
para poder digamos que emprender todas
estas disposiciones legales que además
no fue solamente una demanda sino guerra
nos demandó civilmente por una por un
millón y medio de dólares penalmente
también nos denunció y nos puso dos
tutelas Entonces él agotó todas las
herramientas de la ley además con con
una característica muy importante del
acoso judicial y lo que él buscaba no
era defender sus principios
fundamentales sino
silenciarnos algo que es muy grave que
será más censura previa el el nos pedía
en las conciliaciones que que tuvimos de
los procesos lo que él nos pedía era que
no volviéramos a mencionarlo nunca más y
que retiráramos nuestro reportaje de los
medios Entonces eso eso Pues tiene un un
efecto silenciador e intimidante para
unas periodistas cuyo literalmente cuyo
trabajo es dar a conocer casos de
interés público y como Ciro guerra es
una figura pública y el problema de la
violencia sexual es un problema
sistemático de la sociedad este caso era
de interés público y nosotras nuestra
responsabilidad era informar sobre ello
Porque además al callar este caso pues
se deslegitimaría el derecho de las
víctimas a contar su historia y aquí le
quiero preguntar por ese tema porque
aquí Lo importante ni siquiera es usted
ni Catalina ni guerra mucho menos yo
aquí Lo importante es la historia que
tiene una víctima para contar en este
caso ocho denuncias de acuoso y abuso
ocho mujeres que alzaron su voz a través
de ustedes de volcánicas como medio ya
que nada esta batalla legal que cree
usted que puede pasar con estas mujeres
ellas por supuesto También tienen mucho
que celebrar
pues definitivamente este es un fallo
absolutamente reparador y las fuentes
que nos contaron estas historias que
además no fueron solamente Ocho cuando
cuando en segunda instancia un juez
falló la tutela a favor decir o guerra
nosotras nos vimos obligadas a ampliar
la información de nuestro reportaje y la
manera en la que lo hicimos fue
agregando un caso adicional
de presunto acoso sexual por parte de
Ciro guerra a otra fuente entonces todas
estas mujeres
se sienten absolutamente vindicadas y
reparadas con este fallo porque es un
fallo que definitivamente las protege y
lo que caracteriza al periodismo
feminista es un cuidado absoluto de las
fuentes y de las mujeres que cuentan
estas historias un proceso que es
completamente cuidadoso de sus emociones
de su salud mental de su voluntad
respetuoso de las maneras y de las
formas en las que ellas quieren contar
sus historias entonces
entonces ellas esto es un triunfo para
ellas también que que haciendo parte de
una sociedad en donde el sistema legal
todavía es absolutamente insuficiente y
primordial primordialmente
revictimizante ellas eligieron la vida
periodística para contar sus historias
Pues pensando que esto iba a disminuir
el impacto que que tendría en sus vidas
hablar de de cosas tan traumáticas
entonces que la corte proteja este
reportaje pues protege también la
decisión que ellas tomaron de hablar a
través de nosotros mire esta semana
estaba leyendo una columna feminista en
la que la periodista decía que denunciar
una violencia que una mujer que sufre
violencia la denuncia es prácticamente
un suicidio Porque nada de los sistemas
judiciales ni de Derechos Humanos están
a favor de las mujeres ahora ese mismo
riesgo lo lo están viviendo las perio o
las defensoras o las abogadas llámese
quien sea que esté dispuesto a hablar y
abogar por estos casos Así que diríamos
que ustedes también como periodistas se
corren un riesgo a título personal al
publicar denuncias que por supuesto
culturalmente no van a estar favorecidas
definitivamente
justo después de que salió el fallo puse
un Twitter en donde decía que el
feminismo que el periodismo feminista es
un trabajo en equipo con costos muy
altos el costo que tuvo para nosotros
publicar estas denuncias fue altísimo
pues literalmente un posible costo de un
millón y medio de dólares que nunca en
ningún momento podríamos nosotras pagar
a partir de nuestro oficio y también un
costo en nuestra salud mental muy alto
o sea estar doblemente demandada y
doblemente en tuteladas eso a mí
personalmente me ha afectado muchísimo
sin mencionar que interrumpe nuestro
nuestra libertad de prensa
que no nos permite investigar
tranquilamente eso eso es lo que llaman
los abogados el chilling effect que
tienen las persecuciones judiciales de
personas poderosas que quieren
literalmente tumbar silenciar las
historias que hay en contra de ellos
entonces Claro que que es un riesgo alto
que se corre y por eso este fallo de la
corte es tan conmovedor porque es que
realmente nos protege de una manera tan
integral y tan comprensiva y respalda la
responsabilidad y el sentido ético con
el que hicimos este trabajo entonces no
nos podríamos sentir más satisfechas ya
nos quedamos sin tiempo Matilde muy
Lamentablemente pero ya para cerrar
quisiera tocar con usted un último tema
y es que en general las violencias
machistas la mayoría de veces no se
denuncian y no quedan en registros
principalmente porque tenemos la cultura
de que nada va a pasar a nadie le va a
importar no se puede comprobar no se
puede narrar nadie nos va a creer
Entonces el artículo de las ocho
denuncias contra Ciro guerra muestra que
se pueden relatar las historias pueden
salir los testimonios Y si puede haber
repercusión
Pues sí yo creo que
este reportaje es
fundamental para demostrar una nueva
manera de respaldar a las mujeres que
quieran hacer una denuncia a través del
periodismo creo que le da mucho sentido
a nuestra profesión creo que le abre las
puertas a mujeres que se han sentido
revictimizadas por el sistema
y yo creo que definitivamente es es un
trabajo que es paradigmático mucho más
ahora con el con el respaldo de la corte
constitucional porque es que el nivel de
impunidad y de revictimización en los
casos de denuncia de violencia sexuales
enorme o sea lo que prima en los casos
de denuncia de violencia sexual es la
impunidad entonces y lo que busca tanto
el Scratch como el periodismo feminista
es que haya algún tipo de consecuencia
así sea digamos una sanción social
O al menos el conocimiento del del
público para que estos hechos
puede suceder y para poder contribuir a
la lucha importantísima en la que nos
pasamos los días y las noches para que
las mujeres podamos vivir unas vidas
libres de violencia y con rigurosidad
como debe ser Matilde mire Me quedaría
hablando con usted porque tengo todavía
mucho que decirle pero ya no tenemos
tiempo así que simplemente cierro
nuevamente felicitándola y con la frase
para usted y para nuestros televidentes
En definitiva el periodismo será
feminista gracias a usted y gracias a
todos los que nos ven en France 24 nos
vemos Próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]